I grew up in a family with two amazing
moms my mom Jane gave birth to my
brother Jonah and my mom Deb gave birth
to me this is a photo of all of us at
their wedding day after marriage
equality was passed in Massachusetts but
even growing up in liberal Boston our
family structure was still unusual to
some it was unnatural people even
questioned whether we were a real family
they would say things like isn't it like
weird that you and your brother aren't
biologically related no he's my brother
do you wish you knew your dad no I've
never thought of my parents sperm donor
as my dad but like do you think you
might be gay because your parents are
gay well I don't know those first two
questions were easy because our families
loved definitively did not depend on
genetic connection but they were
frustrating and constant reminders of
how important genetic connection was to
other people but that last question
really got me thinking because by the
time I was 17 years old even though I
had a boyfriend I had kind of started to
develop a crush on a girl in my school
so I thought am I and if so why so I set
out in search of an explanation I opened
my computer and typed into Google two
words
gauging
that Google search for an explanation
for my feelings launched a ten year
journey of learning about genetics
I took genetics classes in college
consulted for genetics companies and I'm
studying it again here at Stanford and I
want to share with you what I've learned
first and foremost this stuff is really
complicated a big part of who we are is
our DNA and our environment our DNA is
the biological matter that carries our
genetic code and our environment is
where we grew up who we surrounded
ourselves with and what events happened
in our lives it would be great if we
could hold DNA constant and adjust our
environment to see which would be more
powerful in which circumstance but
unfortunately it's not that simple we
can ever truly disentangle our DNA from
our environment because they're
constantly interacting and changing each
other and they change us so it's futile
to ask which is more important because
it is only through their interaction
that they can change things like our
health human behavior and who we are and
become so I want to walk through three
really complex examples to explain how
this works and I'm gonna break them down
into their most essential parts let's
start with an example that affects our
mental health by looking at a study on
depression scientists identified a
genetic profile linked to depression for
simplicity let's call it D gene
scientists looked at kids with T gene
and without D gene to see why some
developed depression and others don't
they found that kids with D gene who had
negative experiences such as the loss of
a family member or serious illness were
two times as likely as kids with
outd Jean to develop depression but they
also found that kids with D gene who had
not had negative experiences were no
more likely than kids without D gene to
develop depression the lack of an
experiential factor essentially
equalized the chances that kids would
develop depression regardless of whether
they had D gene and we also know that
50% of people with depression have no
genetic history for it which means you
can have D gene and never develop
depression or you can live with
depression and have no genetic
connection to it so now that we've
talked about an example in human health
let's talk about an example in human
behavior specifically friendly or
pro-social behavior versus aggressive
behavior scientists thought that they'd
identified a gene linked to aggression
let's call it a gene they looked at
people with a gene to study the
prevalence of friendly versus aggressive
behaviors and first they looked at
people with aging who had had aversive
life events such as neglect in the first
two years of their lives they found a
statistically significant relationship
between aversive life events and
exhibiting aggressive behavior but
interestingly they also found that
people with aging who had had positive
experiences actually exhibited more
friendly behavior than people without
aging so had scientists really found the
aggression gene or had they found the
friendly gene aging itself doesn't
determine whether we'll be friendly or
aggressive our environment plays a huge
role as well when it comes to health and
behavior scientists presumably are
looking to get to the root of a problem
to improve our individual and societal
well-being but I want to switch gears
and talk about something that shouldn't
be viewed as a problem but is often
studied in the same way so now let's get
back
- what got this whole genetics research
party started
sexuality for decades scientists have
tried to find the gay gene without much
success they're having trouble testing
their hypothesis because first and
foremost multiple genes are involved in
any complex human trait scientists know
that a minimum of two but up to 16 genes
could influence our eye color alone so
how could one determine sexuality and
even when we know the genes that are
involved our environment plays a huge
role as well but it's not just testing
the hypothesis that's a problem it's
defining it that's been challenging as
well because what are scientists trying
to identify by finding a gay gene anyway
and why is it who we're capable of being
attracted to who were capable of loving
or how we identify when it comes to
sexuality there are so many variables
involved and they're complex fluid
non-binary and socially influenced so
this complicates scientists ability to
even define terms like sexuality gender
love attraction what's genetic and
what's not and yet somehow when I was 17
years old I somehow expected those
scientists and their studies to define
me so why did I do it why did I Google
gauging why did I think it was so simple
why did I need an explanation for my
feelings why did I need to know why and
why does anyone need to know why I
realize that I googled gauging to begin
with because my whole life I got in
question after question after question
reinforced that our genetics made a real
family that only genetic connection is
legitimate that our genetics could
predestined who I become so we shouldn't
use words like genetic or biological or
natural as synonyms for normal because
that's how I internalized them and it
sent me on a 10-year journey to study
something that I ultimately find really
fascinating but that started as me
seeking an explanation for my feelings
as if they were a problem to be solved
now I know that my family my sexuality
my identity they're not problems at all
and they don't require an explanation no
one should have to Google anything to
justify their existence because whoever
you are is okay whether it's found to be
true for you genetically from the
beginning or becomes true for you if
I've learned anything from all of this
it's that our families our identities
our health our behavior basically
anything about us cannot be reduced to
genetics alone because humans are such
so much more complicated than that
so yes genetic discoveries have
tremendous potential to benefit
humankind but genetics does not define
our humanity not my mom's not my
brother's not mine and not yours
[Applause]
[Music]